hi guys it's silver at again with
another episode of the let's play and
honestly I'm not even getting that much
work done in this episode it's just a
general episode in which I decide to do
some random stuff just some simple path
works and other things that I really
needed to do in this area and it's
actually for one main reason that's
still bugging me and I'm still trying to
fix it because it's actually a huge
problem and I'm I've been talking about
this earlier but Webber's large rocks
just keeps crashing on me and there's
actually a major issue since i've been
using it for years and it's always been
working and I used it for the majority
of the rocks in this park already but
for some reason nowadays it just keeps
crashing my game I place about one or
two rocks and then it boom it's gone so
that's actually a major problem and I
tried actually downloading a newer
version because he said that the old
version was indeed booked for some
reason so I downloaded the newer version
and install that but it's still crashed
so I'm still trying to fix that somehow
but today I'm just going to do some
simple stuff like this this tunnel over
here tunnels honestly they they really
annoy me in roller coast icon 3 it's
just because the mechanics with the
terraforming and stuff like that I was
somewhere weird and sometimes they
really nag me though this tunnel wasn't
all that bad I still want to put some
things in it like I don't exactly know
what but I don't want to make it look as
boring as it looks now and of course I'm
still going to add fences around this
and perhaps even some trees at flowers I
literally have no idea what I'm going to
do with this area I just like the idea
of having the paths and having a looping
just kind of go underneath well not
underneath the past but kind of go above
the group I don't even know how to
explain it but I like the idea that's
basically one trying to say and is this
general bath area is definitely probably
way too big like the problem that I have
with these paths is there's so much path
we're going on when you compare it to
how many buildings or other attractions
there are because there's basically not
really anything so all this path work
over here it's just there to look fancy
and it still kind of annoys me in a
sense that it looks somewhat unnecessary
so I still want to do something with
this or play
foliage all around it so that it at
least looks less well open and less like
it's a square because I'm not even
trying to make a square but I still like
this path work though it just doesn't
make that much sense but I liked a
general look of this and of course I'm
trying to get the textures again don't
exactly know what kind of textures I
used before but I guess that'll be fine
and for the queue i figured i would
actually make a wooden walkway that we
kind of hover above the rocks that i
want to make in this area and i don't
know exactly why i wanted to do that it
just came up in my hand and I figured
might as well go for it so that's what
I'm doing and I don't know I just feel
like I really like doing rock work and
adding flowers and ferns and all kinds
of cool crunch robbery and foliage
around it so I just figured i would give
it a shot and try doing this though to
be fair the cure is somewhat short and I
still kind of suck at q's like many
people have been I've been talking to me
about this and yeah I must admit I
really suck at q's I haven't even done
that much research on them or I don't
really know much about theme parks in
general actually but I feel like I I
just want to make used our aesthetically
pleasing so to speak so I figured I
would just do this because I like
flowers definitely flowers are awesome
and you can expect me spamming loads of
flowers in this area because I don't
know why but it's just it's just cool so
yeah that's that now of course like i
said i'm just doing random little things
in this episode and it's pretty much all
over the place it's pretty much those
things that aren't really that creative
but you just have to do them too well
you don't have to do them but i just
have to do them I like I I think so
because it just looks things look it
just makes things look better like these
borders are right the paths it's a
simple little touch but it definitely
makes the site walk stick out more and
makes the general area look just a bit
better and here is where I tried to
place Weber's lunch box and then it
crashed so I was like okay screw that
i'm just going to procrastinate that and
work on my borders and i still need to
fix Weber's large rocks oh yeah that's
going to be
tough time I might I might actually try
to reinstall it today and do some tests
with it because I definitely do want to
get that set to work because it looks
great and I really want to use it though
to be fair Weber also came out with yeah
he also made a newer version of the set
the medium rocks so I should use that as
well because it's awesome and of course
i'm earning wooden borders again because
you know I I sometimes don't see I
sometimes see people not using any
wooden fences but wooden fences
especially when you've got a well park
like this which is kind of Alpine or if
you've got for example western inch park
while anything in which the buildings
have wooden stuff in it all right or
farm themed anything basically wooden
fences are just amazing and station Jim
Spencer's are awesome so I I really
sometimes need to force myself not to
use those things because if I really
wanted to i could really over use those
things because they're so awesome and I
at that point I realized that I still
like the station unfinished and even
though i'm not that content with the
station in their way is right now i just
decided to finish it maybe i can later
on add some small finishing touches like
pipes or other things to make it more
steampunk ish even though the entire
theme that I'm going for is kind of
weird I just figured you know I really
need to finish that top pipe my OCD
didn't ya while couldn't accept the fact
that part of the building was still
unfinished and I had that ugly little
thing on the roof that was basically
nothing so just adding some windows and
other odds and ends to it of course door
to the balcony I don't exactly know the
function of that but the thing is with
the roofs I have a thing where I don't
like it when I see your roof and there's
nothing on it I want to at least have
something on my roofs I don't know if
that's something that everyone has but i
just find it I just find that it looks
better so whether it's dormers or a
weird thing that sticks out like this I
just want to add something to my roofs I
don't want to have a flat surface so
that's why I'm doing this also the
general shape of the building is a bit
better due to this thing because it's
not as straight and boring and square
some of
that's really cool and yeah I really
like that balcony up there I don't know
why but I have a thing for balconies
they're awesome and at that point I was
like hmm I'm ice but i might as well
spend these iron works because that's
how steampunk works you just spams steal
things and then you call it steampunk
but anyway that's this episode so see in
the next one and thanks for watching